I've always done writing as part of
everything that I've done in the past
just various creative enterprises I
write songs and do music and write
essays and you know short plays and
sketch comedy and all these things and
there during my 20s I was living in
Chicago and probably pursuing everything
creatively that i can think of all at
once and waiting for something to choose
me I got a job right out of graduate
school working for a local television
show in in Chicago and so I was doing
writing for that but I was also writing
music and I was doing a little bit of
performing I was writing plays and and
also performing on stage and doing the
music thing and playing coffeehouses and
blues clubs and ultimately I was just
waiting for something to choose me and
what happened was somebody suggested
well why don't you write a screenplay
for a movie and I thought well I like
movies and so I wrote one and and looked
at it and said that was fun I didn't
like that particular screen plane didn't
do anything with it but then I wrote
another one and sent it out and somebody
bought it and all of a sudden I was a
screenwriter and I thought that was easy
I'll do this and so I just kept doing it
and I haven't had any reason to do
anything else since
good this isn't that good part writing a
screenplay is not so hard that's all
about knowing where the margins are for
writing a good screenplay is almost
impossible I I think it's it part of it
has to do with being original trying to
do something that feels fresh when
there's been so many movies made and and
also particularly in Hollywood a
tendency to try and remake the same
movies over and over again so it's
writing a movie that's original that
becomes really difficult and there's
something very formal about the
enterprise of writing a screenplay it
can't be longer than two hours so the
kind of story you tell whatever it is it
has to be as engaging in as exciting as
possible within that one and a half to
two hour period and that forces certain
kind of conventions on you places where
oh we really want to have them gripped
in the story by here or else they're
going to leave or change the channel or
or walk out of the theater there's a
certain kind of efficiency built into
screenwriting that's that's very elegant
but that makes it as hard to craft is a
very finely crafted piece of sculpture
furniture something like that and and
making it all come alive when you just
start putting together all the pieces of
things that you visualize that would be
wonderful it all seems in your mind to
be wonderful but then what when you look
at what you've created on the page it's
like a Frankenstein's monster you've got
a head you've got the hands you got the
feet you've got the body you thought of
everything and when you look at it it's
still just a bunch of dead meat lying
there on the table and you try to get a
pulse to go through the thing what makes
it real it's a complete artifice it's
completely made up it's all these things
from your head and your desires and
dreams and you know it isn't real yet
and somehow something has to spark off
the page that makes you to join the life
that's going on in this world that
you've created and to make that smooth
life feel real when the whole thing is
artifice it all has a
it's all people you've created in worlds
that don't even exist making that feel
real that's that's the absolute
impossible thing being original making
it feel real and making it all fit it's
it's the easiest thing in the world and
it's absolutely impossible
screenwriting is an art form but it's
also a craft it's both of those things
it's a commercial art and both of those
things you need to be good at I if you
just know the craft and you don't have
any sense of the art that means you
don't have anything to say and you don't
have an interesting way to say it if
it's all art and no craft then you've
got these great ideas but you are unable
to articulate them in a way that makes
it all work out as a good blueprint for
building a great movie so I I definitely
think there's there's a great deal of
artistry involved I've never seen a good
screenplay that was nothing but craft